you want to be experienced and you want
to experience it but women shouldn't
have a lot of bodies no she asked me
like if i would get married yeah how
many men is too many men
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today it is my
first time going to carnival i'm a
little nervous because i've heard some
crazy things so we're gonna see how it
goes but today we are interviewing
people on what is their body count and
how many bodies there's too many bodies
if you like the topic like the video
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell and let's get started
sleeping around different for men and
for women i don't know i think whatever
people want to do
like if they're sleep if they're if like
a woman's like body count like is higher
than like a guy's like it shouldn't
matter
it matters to a lot of guys though yeah
for some reason it doesn't compete in my
brain as to why it does but they do view
it differently it just held to another
standard where they can sleep with
literally anyone and the minute a woman
does it's like oh well you're a slag or
like there's like the massive discourse
where it's like your vagina gets massive
which is a complete lie because you push
a baby out and then it stretches back so
it's like if you push a baby out and
your vagina can stretch back then why
does it matter how many people you sleep
with like that doesn't change it you
know what i mean but as a man they can
just go with whoever and it's like oh
you're a lad like that's sick no 100 i
testified to that and i feel like a lot
of like particularly in like this
straight community they and like the
patriarchal ideals are very much like
keep this old like victorian like
ideology where a woman has to be like
virginal to be like attracted i agree
with them no
you don't think so no what about you
society says yes i say no no no i don't
think so so if you were talking to a guy
is there a body count that would be too
high for you to talk to
like if you said i've slept with a
thousand women yeah no it's a no for me
yeah it's you know a thousand women
to be honest you know like how um men
are swimming like how many people have
you slept with that never comes into our
question yeah it's never a thing
because it's like that's your past
that's whatever it is it doesn't really
matter no i think it's uh you do it
differently no no debut differently i
don't know oh right now i don't think i
review it differently if i had the same
body count between a man and a woman i
think it would be like i wouldn't think
anything of it i didn't think no no i
wouldn't it's almost like i sleep around
a lot i'd be like as long as you're
clean from stds can i i i do view it
differently but i'll tell you why i'll
tell you what i'll tell you what i'll
tell you why because i think like women
have to in general and i know there's
exceptions but by and large like have to
be more attached and like like a guy
more and it's like easy for a woman to
get sex where guys they have to earn it
like a guy a guy has to be a certain
height for you to be attracted to him he
has to be a certain level of income
certain level of like everything though
don't they no not really if you look at
the data you know what percent of the
time women swipe right on dating apps
oh god yeah like women swipe right five
to ten percent of the time where men
swipe right fifty percent
men are like is she hot in there yeah
is she hot there and willing just like
okay you guys are pretty girls right you
go out and you ask ask 10 guys if they
want to have sex you'll get to take her
go get a secret but him it's not going
to be the same if he goes up to 10 10
girls that says do you want to have sex
with me they're going to look at him
like he's nuts or the guys will be like
when and where
but men are probably more likely to do
that though like go up to someone and be
like hey i don't know yeah i feel like
you have a point with that what's the
point what's the point
i feel like you know let's go after
girls a bit more than girls go after men
and i guess that kind of proves your
point like it's like harder for them to
get like do you know one out of three
men is either a virgin or hasn't had sex
in the past year i really yeah no way i
actually whoa i want to start
feasibility because it's like maybe i
shouldn't i shouldn't be jumping to
conclusions do you think body count
doesn't matter of course no what's your
body count i don't count not that i'm
saying it's a lot roughly only count
roughly
under 20. yeah oh okay you're more
honest than but everyone tells me virgin
no no because for me it's not like a
show-off thing that i'll say oh yeah
like it's something to show off about
it's just like a
you know
guys mostly amongst men like oh yeah
i've slept with this many but with women
it's not that much i think it's more
emotional than physical
asking my question
i would never answer that like even if
god was standing in front of me
even if god was standing in front of me
the only reason i asked that is because
if it doesn't matter what doesn't
everyone just say
like i don't actually i don't actually
care what your body counts are but like
like and so everyone today i asked the
context because then like where is that
gonna go if i'd like to randomly save my
body account like it could go anywhere i
have some [ __ ] to say but we can talk
about it after this
it's just interesting you know what i
mean like it's like if it really didn't
matter why don't we all just tell each
other yeah and we do you'll be surprised
i think people do somebody drink too
hard yeah exactly
would you say that because it's more
emotional for us that sleeping around is
different because we have to have an
emotional connection where men will just
screw anything i mean i don't i can't
speak for all men
in general right for myself like yeah i
think it's more like emotional rather
than just physical yeah if i connect
with you then i connect with you well i
think that's why i think that's why like
men say it's different is because like
we have to like be a ted we have to like
him in some way where a dude can screw a
girl he hates that's it we need to have
some type of physical some kind of
emotional we need to connect in some way
so you kind of understand where they're
coming from a little bit pretty
reasonable if i understand but i i don't
know i can't really answer that okay do
you think body count matters yeah yeah
yes it does yeah why do you think so
many people say it doesn't because
they're liars
because they're capping
would you say your body count
i i don't
no no
no the only reason i ask usually people
will say it doesn't matter and then i'll
ask like what's your body count because
they say it doesn't matter see we're not
liars yeah at least you guys are honest
i don't know if i believe the virgin
thing no i swear i would not mind it
would it wouldn't affect me at all no if
he's the one if he's the one do you guys
believe in the one yeah i do
i feel like that's like a disney like i
feel like there's just like choices and
trade-offs and you get to like like no
one's there's not one there's not one
person that's like the one i think there
is
so if you're watching put your edgy put
your eyes oh no no no no no no
we got it
we'll find it hey come here real quick
they're fake
come on yeah
i know your channels oh yeah um is it
just anything
yeah i thought you were looking at me
earlier
i was like i was like i was like i felt
like
the question today
is is sleeping around different for men
and for women oh definitely because men
hold no emotional attachment women kind
of like will hold an emotional
attachment if that makes sense so he he
says he says it matters he says it's
different what do you say how's it
different women hold more emotional
attachment like generally if you're if
you were to [ __ ] with a guy you wouldn't
go in it to be like oh yeah i'm just
having sex you're gonna want him to know
you all of that [ __ ] compared to like
i'm just being serious generalized it's
different for everyone yeah it's
different i know there's girls out there
that don't ever like want to do all that
[ __ ] but then majority of girls would
have feelings towards the guy you're not
going to pick up some random guy that
looks like a four of a five out of ten
and just be like yeah and i'll allow him
to smash i think the question was sorry
i'm like taking your spot as an
interviewer the question was how do you
do you see it differently between men
have no like if a guy wants to mess with
a girl he has no emotional attachment
you do see it differently i generally
see most men have no emotional
attachment when it comes to sex okay if
you if me or you wanted to get sex all
we have to do is go around and say
anyone want to have sex we'd have people
lined up if he if he if he did this
right now he would he's a good look he's
a good looking guy if he went he went
around and did that he's sliding in no
no i'm saying i'm saying i'm saying look
at look look i'm just i'm being real
like if he goes around asking girls for
sex they're gonna be like no get the
[ __ ] away from me but me and you me and
you all we have to do is ask
but i personally don't see it different
if a girl told me she has a thousand
bodies so people like a guy that looks
like me
everybody
we should hold like the same standards
that's what you mean yes but like in
reality it's not the same and this yeah
like in reality it's not but the
question was what do i think and i
wouldn't think of a woman less than i do
a man if they have the same body count
as what i was saying
to say this if it's an average looking
guy do you think he would have as much
success to a guy that's way more good
looking in a general sense so for to get
a woman or if he's trying to get her in
bed or relationship status whatever it
is do you think that will happen no but
i think it's the same way with women an
average looking girl and an average girl
would have a better chance with any type
of guy she would want i'm just gonna i'm
just gonna put this in perspective i i
consider myself average i literally do
i've no no i know girls will always
correct me but like i'm just being real
like i feel like most people are normal
looking and i feel like i'm normal
looking and i've had i've had nba
players slide in my dms
it's not it's not a flex it's not a flex
they're looking it's not it's not look
at look at that we're not gonna look at
like we're not gonna i'm saying i'm
saying like that's not a flex though
they're just looking for easy sex and so
i'm saying like that would never happen
like to a guy where like a blue check
mark girl is gonna slide in his dms of
just a normal guy
i have a question would you say body
count doesn't matter
i don't care at all so what's your body
count
[Music]
if it doesn't every time it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter right
um 15 50
no 1-5 no 15 15 15
15 okay 14 14 mine's one one really i
have boyfriends okay okay
you know you know it's crazy you guys
are the most honest we're like everyone
else have asked virgin i'm a virgin
i don't give a [ __ ]
the only reason i ask is because if it
doesn't matter then everyone should just
say it and that's why i hesitated a bit
because i was like oh my god but then
it's like do you actually care like
if it doesn't matter like why i don't
know what i mean it makes no difference
to my life it doesn't change me as a
person like it has nothing to do with my
personality or anything so devil's
advocate do you think that sex is
different for men and for women and like
the way we experience sex so like we
have to have more of an emotional
connection with a guy i wouldn't say
much of an emotional connection i say is
different in the sense of like amounts
of effort that are put in and i think a
lot of the industry and like the sexual
industry is based around a man's
pleasure not a woman's and like there
was a
statistic and it was like literally 65
percent of women i'm just saying
ballpark yeah i can't remember it but
they were like they watched lesbian play
because it's based around like women's
pleasures so people get off easy to it
like most of the marketing is geared
towards women not that so not for corn
you're correct like for corn is
definitely geared towards men but 70 to
80 of consumer buying decision decisions
are made by women like women have more
debt even though they make less money
because we spend more money than men do
by and large so like society actually
isn't really geared towards men is
geared towards women so like that's why
we have like like plus size models for
example like men typically like they
date smaller girls you're like just by
by and large right not trying to you
know but like that's for the women it's
not for the men yeah well like i think
women want that as well like women want
to see you don't want to go and buy a
item of clothing that's shown on like a
size 4 model because you don't know how
it's going to look on your body type so
i think the brands that show like say
even just three different body types
it's like so much better because at
least people know what kind of ballpark
they're going to especially with buying
online and how big it's because no i
you're right but like the only point i
was making is that it's geared for women
it's not geared for men so like a lot of
times we'll say like we're in a
patriarch where everything's like geared
towards men but it's it's not because
women are spending the money
which we don't even have because there's
a gender fake up in the first place it's
like ah you know
that's a whole other camera i know it's
closing but you know no it's it's like
based on the industries we pick so like
women pick jobs that make less money
like by and large like for example do
you want to be a plumber no
how many bodies is too many bodies for
someone you want to date like if they
said a thousand would you be cool a
thousand i'd just be shocked i'd be like
how the [ __ ] do you have the time to see
all these you must be seeking like one
person a day and different people all
the time like just how do you have the
time in your personal space i just think
as long as you're up to date with your
sexual health and as long as you care
about your body and care about the
people you are sleeping with and have
respect for them i don't care how many
people you've slept with as long as you
just have respect for my sexual health
on your own that's it like a thousand
you'd be chilling a thousand i'd just be
like what the [ __ ] like how on earth
could you possibly get to that point
that would be my only reservation but
i'd be like look have you been to the
clinic like do you you know look after
yourself if you look after yourself i
don't care who you've slept with how
many people whatever as long as you're
you know just respectful of us in like
an intimate space okay that's it yeah no
i agree i don't think like for me it's
not really a factor that i consider if
i'm in a relationship like as long as
i'm like the only person that's fine
what they did in the past like it's
their body it's their life they could do
what the [ __ ] they want yeah i think i
don't think it'd be like a deal breaker
but again i'd be shocked
i've probably questioned it i just think
like as well it's also nobody else's
business how many people you've set with
i think the person that you're sleeping
with that's new
their only business with you is to be
like well are you like are you within
sexual health or are you sexually ill in
that sense i don't think it's anyone's
business to even ask you like how many
people have you set with because like
you're that's a new partner like you
shouldn't be talking about past sexual i
mean you can talk about passion i always
i always ask i always ask but like it's
like the only thing i'd ask someone is
like have you got anything are you
sexually safe you know whatever and like
i would never be like oh how many people
are stuck with that's disgusting you
know what i mean i have a question when
i'm asking like i ask a guy that
sometimes but the reason i do is because
i'm trying to gauge if he's ready to
settle down
because to me like i really want to get
married and have a family and like if i
do stuff with a thousand girls i'm like
i'm gonna be a thousand and one and lock
you down yeah and piercing like i was
single for a really long time and i'm
just really picky with a relationship so
like i should be yeah exactly and like
everyone was just kind of like and there
was a lot of boys that were like oh she
seeps around and i don't even like sleep
around that much based on like say the
general population not that i care if i
did but they were kind of like oh well
she like it's almost like the
connotation that you'll cheat on them
because you're sexually active yeah and
it's like faithfulness in a relationship
has no correlation to how many people
you've slept with like within you know
what the divorce rate does
yeah yeah it's like if a girl is a
virgin she has an 80 chance of a happy
marriage where if she slept with more
than five it drops to 25 but also men
too they don't talk about this but like
men like the hat the longest the best
results are when both are virgins is
that not the sense of like kind of the
science of it when it's like did it say
it releases like um um like oxytocin or
something like that and then you become
like attached to that person so if
you're a virgin and you marry someone
and then they take your virginity like
you have that like mental attachment
literally through science
so that's my only explanation for it
well i think it's the psychology of
choice yeah like if you'd slept with a
hundred guys like you're you're gonna
there's gonna be a lot of them that you
liked yeah and so it's like when you're
with the new guy like you can't help but
compare in some way like people people
act like they don't but like i'm sorry
you're going i think it's also good to
have a comparison though because you
kind of as you're going along and as
you're growing up and as you're with
different people like you get to know
what you like and what you deserve as
well which is i think is really
important and like you know like the
kind of personality you want and like
it's not even down to like a lot of the
time it's not for me it's not down to
like attractiveness or anything because
like somebody we could be absolutely
gorgeous and be boring or not have the
same music taste as me or not like the
same events as me and like you know i
mean i'd rather go over someone that i'm
necessarily not like oh my god i love
you like you're so attractive but more
like oh my god you have a sick
personality you're really funny you're
like the same events me the same music
as me like we're gonna have so much fun
and you know are they curious how old
are you 21. okay okay i hear that from
girls when they say that usually they're
like 27 28 yeah where they like don't
want the like the bad boys anymore like
the hot guys but i'm just so you're
you're early i'm over it like i'm bored
like i don't mind a bad boy if it's not
going to be a long term thing because
then i'm like i don't have to deal with
people they're not [ __ ] they don't make
good boyfriends
i don't care about a bad boy like i'll
sleep with them but if they're like oh
do you want to go on a date i'm like no
like i can read you straight away and i
know exactly what kind of person you're
like without being judgmental but how
they speak and how they act i'm like
this is not going to be a relationship
mate this is not i'm i'm curious would
you sleep with a bad boy quicker than
you would sleep with a nice guy it
depends like a guy that you want to date
actually it depends like
personality-wise i like sleeping on the
first date i don't care because it takes
this big discourse about like women
sleeping with someone on the first date
and it's like oh you're not desirable
anymore but it's like it takes two to
tango the man's also set for somebody on
the first date like does it matter like
you oh as if i turn around and be like
oh you set me on the first day what the
hell at the end of the day sex is such a
natural thing
like if you want to if you're like on a
date with someone you're having such a
good time
and you get to that stage why not
because the end of the day if you want
to be together you're going to end up
having sex along the lines so why does
it matter the amount of time like that's
i mean that's one like trade of thought
i've heard a lot of people say is
because like it's like he's either gonna
stay or go after you sleep with him so
it's like i don't care yeah but and then
at the same time it's like you also
don't know him that well so like i don't
know either yeah i i think i've never
slept with a total stranger yeah i've
met people even on dating apps but like
we've had mutual friends so like out of
a point of safety maybe if i completely
didn't know someone i wouldn't sleep
with him but only out of a point of
safety not have a point of being like oh
i stepped on the first day that's the
only reason
like i've literally only like kind of
say gone back after a first day with
people that
like i know have mutual friends with me
and i know that they're like fine never
asked my friends about me if he tries to
steal you like they'll know where you
were
like like you're thinking about that
random guy on a date i'd be like oh yeah
maybe we'll chat a bit more and then
i'll let you know my dress but until
then [ __ ] no it's not happening now
question of the day is how many bodies
is too many bodies for a girl for a girl
as long as there's lower than mine we're
good three ten i think when you're
hitting double digits like 10 10 or over
i think that's a lot yeah if you if
you're on the triple zero then yeah
that's mad if you're in the triples all
right so so girl has she's a 10 but
she's slept with 20 people what is she
back
what's a two bag
twenty twenties oh she's in it well how
okay let's say let's say thirty thirty
just calm down that's calm
any more than double digits
okay from wife in it or if i'm on a
white not one night singing no wife in
it oh no no no no
what's your body count free zero you're
a virgin yeah okay uh come on love pc
yeah you can't tell me no not on youtube
they're like over under 50.
under 50 over under 20. can't confirm
we're going to be interviewing girls
today do you think they'll tell me no no
no no
no i'll do
what's your body color this i'm saying
myself i'm a husband okay call me you
are you virgin let's just say it's on
the 20. okay next question rate yourself
one to ten give myself an ico 11 20. uh
seven on a good day maybe at 8.5 okay so
if you can't use seven you give yourself
an eight maybe it's maybe not seven
seven solid seven is sleeping around
different for men and for women actually
i don't believe in a double standard but
i see if you're single do it but you
still look down upon aren't you i think
it's different for women because we
carry more of an emotional attachment to
it whereas men they just do it for the
sake of doing it
okay see like this here when you're a
woman someone's putting it inside you in
it so so that's unit like that's that's
your sort of space but when it's someone
else it's a man they're just going in
and out they're going to the next one
you know what i mean so it's like for
goals it's more man it's like do you
know what i'm saying i agree yeah yeah
yeah so if there were ever such thing as
too many bodies for a guy that you would
date me no like so if you're interested
in a guy and he says i've slept with
this many people i don't ask the
question because i feel like what you've
done you've done so so you don't it
doesn't matter i don't i don't ask the
question and i don't expect you to trust
me the damn question needs to me that's
your past so i wouldn't let it affect
the future so the average age of first
marriage in the uk is 31. what do you
think the average body count is for a 31
year old woman in the in in today yeah
i would say
i'm going off what the people that i
know i've heard i'd probably say like 20
20 25 i'd say about 18 80.
i was like who do you know
would you rather take a girl with 50k
and in debt and credit card debt or 50
bodies
the what you wife you wife or girl with
50 bodies or with 50k in credit card
debt and if i'm up i'm i'm doing the the
debt if no because this is a nice goal
you help each other out the one in debt
100 okay so you take 50k in debt over
50. she's a good goal she's a good goal
i actually feel so awkward asking people
their body counts
like i feel like
oh my god i get so nervous is sleeping
around different for men and for women
i think simple people process it as
different but they don't look deep
enough i i think there's a double
standard that is exist but i don't
understand why it exists i've been with
my partner for 11 years sleeping around
has never been a problem ethical
non-monogamy is a thing google it
dudes that's [ __ ] haram that what you
guys do yeah man like 11 years oh you
don't get jealous no because we chose
each other right yeah we do you choose
each other every day i could never get
so jealous not if you get broke up
properly because then you're like i'm
not horny because i got good this
morning what's he doing okay i get to
rest it's different
and to be fair like even if you are in a
monogamous relationship asking yourself
and your partner ethical non-monogamous
questions is good for your own
relationship because you create your
relationship based on the boundaries of
the people involved rather than
externally
curated and boxed in versions of what
your relationship should be
there's too much in the media telling
you what your relationship should be
rather than who you are as a person and
personality yeah my question to every
relationship is how has monogamy [ __ ]
your life up and once you can answer
that and answer honestly like so for me
though like when i think of my parents
like if they weren't
listen
but i like because i have nine siblings
so they're they're like monogamous
system yeah yeah that's sister five boys
your father had no pull out game
no everywhere it was kind of just like
half as many as we can they're catholic
yeah so like i'm like wouldn't that be
confusing for kids if like they're
sleeping around around town like it was
always nice growing up where i didn't
have to worry about like any exes or any
like it's it's
two separate things yeah you're not
having your sexual partner relationships
in front of your children all the time
it's the same as having aunts and uncles
your parents best friends around your
children
if they are the people that they are
they're going to be just as loving
you're going to want to spend a day with
your cool auntie or your cool uncle like
if you're at a type in your relationship
where you want to have them around your
children and you want to raise them as a
family it takes a village to raise a
child so why would you limit your child
like we live in a world where it's okay
to be a single parent why
like even with a single parent you still
need someone to support you your mom
your cousin your sister to babysit for a
night if you have to emergency do
something so so why would you not want
to curate that space where they have
multiple adults to raise the child and
multiple adults to check on each other
in their parenting as well i actually
agree with you and that like it's
interesting how like single parents are
normalized but like someone can't have
multiple wives or multiple husbands when
would you think that would be a better
like if i person like i'm just more of a
fan of two but like if i if i had to
pick like a single parent or a group
like if you had to pick between one and
four you'd pick four yeah exactly
no exactly exactly so it's interesting
how like one is illegal and one's legal
yeah i think i think that in terms of
like a single parent no matter who you
are man woman it's not enough yeah like
because yeah like i feel like the
biggest thing that children learn is
seeing their parent get checked by
another adult they learn so much from
that and if there's only one adult and
it's like oh i'm your mom and your dad
it's like how much can i actually learn
from you yeah it's like how much
perspective can i get and by having
multiple adults you get multiple adult
perspectives and it's not even like and
it's not even like just one person it's
when your kid goes to their sporting
games on the weekend their coach is a
role model for them when they go to
their musical field or dance clubs
afterwards it's there's another role of
them their teachers are role models so
they do have adults around them but
you've curated who you choose to be yeah
like
single parents choosing to lower their
ego and understand that other adults can
help you you're right like most of human
history it was like a powerful men with
a bunch of women yeah like typically
over over history only 40 of men
reproduced so it 80 of women did so it
was literally two girls for one guy
depends on what part of history you go
back to but yeah i guess so yeah like
the more choice women have the less that
happens right but
the more choice the women have the less
that happens when you meet yeah well
yeah like so the more you're exposed to
multiple
black cultures and men and different
styles of like raising the family or
just being yourself like i believe that
the more you're exposed to there's less
likely you want to settle for what you
grew up with you know
you're kind of right actually when like
the more women get choice the more like
hypergamous they become so it's like a
smaller well it's a smaller percentage
of men that are screwing all the girls
so it's one out of three men are either
virgins or haven't had sex in the past
year so it's like it's like again it
goes back to like the way it used to be
in a way the more things progress which
you can see from the fight for women's
rights for lgbt trans rights for black
rights the more things progress the
harder the pushback is so you'll you'll
see this back and forth happen but i
think people should have more
opportunities to
see different possibilities and choose
for themselves rather than being told
what they think is right and following
that what do you think would you guys so
would you be cool with like multiple
husbands and multiple wives in this is
that how you want to do it yeah like
it's on the person like honestly like
you're gonna get like a big house but
like but yeah if you wanna say you're
supposed to afford a house like if
you're able to remove your ego and be
like she likes me for me and not because
i'm better than somebody else or not
because i'm worse than somebody else it
makes more sense and i think a lot of
people are too caught up with am i
better than the person in front of me or
like you just need to be happy with who
you are i do that yeah yeah of course of
course like today this morning that am i
going to look good this morning
but but it's like once you understand
who you are and you don't question it
anymore yeah you can truly be yourself
in other spaces and that allows you to
be open to more people because once
you're really yourself people understand
who you are whereas when you're
pretending to be somebody else
everyone's skeptical they're like who's
this guy who's this girl and and that is
that that's the biggest question mark in
life like who are you
it's a lot of responsibility to be one
person's everything and if you're in a
partnership that involves two or more
people it's about choosing the person
for who they are like i can see all the
potentials of who you are and whatever
avenue or pathway you take i want to be
there to witness that yeah like we've
been together for 11 years since we were
16. wow and like we understand that we
choose each other every day like no
matter how much work we have to put in
we choose to put in that work no matter
how much graft we have to put in we
choose to put in that grind and at the
end of it we look back and say we've
grinded harder than any relationship
we've ever seen yeah and so we can be
confident no matter where it goes i mean
you guys you can i'm always a big result
sp speak for themselves and you've been
together long the average marriage is
like seven eight years so you guys have
been together longer than most married
people that was that was expected when
we would have known that when we were 16
to be fair
we spiritually married
why
as
far
need the government to tell you if
you're married or not the government
just tells us what we can do with the
power of marriage
not the commitment to it you know
[Music]
is sleeping around different for men and
for women yes or no yeah men don't have
to face the consequences yeah i think
the same i think yeah when
when women do it it's not really
acceptable that when guys do it's fine i
don't know oh for sure definitely it
depends
less fun though it's not less fun it's
just that women face have to face the
consequences men like just get branded
as like legends and women judge other
women as well for sleeping around i
think but as as you get older at the
moment yeah i think people care less
nowadays if girls sleep
around more younger in school that's
when it's like
some dudes especially with like the
whole andrew tate thing some dudes
actually care about body count and [ __ ]
that's so small do you think body count
matters [ __ ] no in fact the higher the
better you actually know what you're
doing in bed so i have a question would
you guys say your body counts no so if
it doesn't matter like why don't people
just say it i don't know what's your
body say it
but it's just it's just interesting
because we'll say it doesn't matter but
then it's like if it doesn't matter why
doesn't everyone just say it very
intellectual thought because honestly
like for a guy for a guy i think i think
like like personally like i wish i was a
virgin i wish i had waited until
marriage i think one is too many
i i wish i did yeah i really i like i
wish i was a virgin yeah
really you have a relationship you need
to know that the person that you're
gonna marry
is yeah exactly i think we have that
sexual chemistry sexual chemistry is so
important so i i feel like if you wait
you won't know like okay i think it's
different like once you've had sex well
some men are allowed to have fun and
women can't until marriage well i mean i
think it's it's actually if you look at
the stats it's better if they're both
virgins like the longest marriages are
if both people compare it to i guess if
it's your first time you everything
feels great
i don't know
it's just interesting because like when
i ask people they say it doesn't matter
but then no one ever wants guys to eat
too they don't want to say it either
yeah that's what's crazy yeah yeah my
guy friends are like i'd rather not tell
you my body count just
it's like it's just personal information
isn't it
what do you so the average age of first
marriage in the uk is 31. what do you
think the average body count is for a 31
year old woman 40 40.
50 maybe
20.
do you know what's interesting though i
asked guys how many bodies there's too
many bodies they all say 10.
but but that's what i'm saying but
everyone i ask what's the average body
count of first marriage it's above 10 so
it's like it seems like someone's
capping yeah they're not being realistic
but there's definitely for females
there's a lot more body count than males
i think you're you're right one out of
three men are either virgins or they
haven't had sex in the past year so
that's that's the thing like the reason
girls say men are trash and like you
guys have this perception that men are
sleeping around like not you but like
it's like a like
in general but it's because like we're
all sleeping with the same guys because
it's only five percent of men get
matches really on tinder that's mad yeah
so if you if you hook up with a guy off
on an online like you're one of like
sleeping around is it different for men
and for women yeah why because there's
like a stereotype in it that obviously
women should be not sleeping around and
mentioning
but i mean women should because at the
end of the day if you're single why not
or is it the same spiritually the same
what do you think i think it used to be
but not anymore would you be cool with
the girl that slept with 500 men that's
her own business you can do what she
wants no i'm saying would you would you
marry her i mean if she's good to me
either i wouldn't i probably wouldn't
but i don't think i wouldn't expect
loads of girls to marry me if i did do
you feel like it's the same in society
it's treated equally no not through
everyone yeah do you think body count
matters no
what's your body count
three three yeah
that's funny that's what we said people
would say tonight
before we came out i haven't got a high
body count but it shouldn't matter but
you know what i mean it's just
interesting because everyone says it
doesn't matter but a lot of times people
don't want to say it
[Music]
is sleeping around different for men and
for women yes or no is sleep is sleeping
around different for men and for
why
because guys when they can get away with
anything and us girls get labeled i mean
it can be the same you know we are men
so it can't be the same it can't be the
same cannot you cannot why because men
have the intensity
we feel the intensity of them of the
movement of the the music
deep down
what do you think what do you think for
me the same sleeping around different
for men and for women yeah why because
not only the same [ __ ] bro
men are supposed to stay loyal but it's
just when we when we go around it
doesn't mean anything when girls do it
it does mean something is that do you
think that's fair it's not fair at all
we're gonna live our lives do you think
body count matters if you're dating a
guy do you care what his body counts i
don't [ __ ] care i want a question
will you will you tell him if he asks
you a lie
how many how many bodies is too many
bodies for you to wife a girl 10 10 10
no okay chill bro 15 15. 50 20 50
because
because the girls here are different
yeah yeah
i'm from america i don't know
london women are special we love them
there's no numbers to it i don't think
no number so a hundred you're cool i'm
cool with 100 yeah
jesus you called the hundreds
of 100 bodies to go in the snow yet
about 100 we cool 100 we cool what's
your body count
the question of the day is is sleeping
around different for men and for women
personally yeah definitely yeah
men have one functionality if we
simplify things that's to impregnate
women women have one functionality if we
simplify things that's to give birth
nine months okay how many girls can get
pregnant in nine months oh just just by
one yeah yeah why because if you're a
woman and you're sleeping around you
probably get bv you probably get other
stis
well amen is not so
he a man can catch people yeah
so shall i be
socially i cannot speak english anymore
my friends
so you say body count matters um no
no
man say yes but we don't care
um that's a personal preference for you
for me that's a personal preference but
each to their own and that's that's my
take on it so what's your body count
eight one
one babe i lost calories
because you're not laughing
why am i caring this month
where am i going
why am i carrying though like what
benefit is that well the reason i i ask
is because people often will say it
doesn't matter and so if i say if it
doesn't matter what's your body count
well i just lost count like why would i
count yeah so you try that yeah right so
you stand by it like if you knew you'd
probably tell me but a lot of people
wouldn't that's yeah my body count is
one so hey there's [ __ ] is that
true her body counts one uh
i see i see what you did there how many
bodies is too many bodies for you to
wife a girl my body count is one no my
body got zero actually i'm a liar my
body has zero so
my girl cannot be less than zero
realistically because i've met a lot of
virgins people that claim they're
virgins i'm a virgin claim i don't like
that word i don't like it
you are virgins how old are you guess my
age 28 25 no no you're spot on
your spot on your spot
i'm a 28 year old virgin co-signing
why have you waited this because i have
prestige and self-respect it's not any
girl that can you know i mean okay okay
so he's a virgin you're co-signing this
we're all a virgin out here like a lot
that can be opened by any key yeah it's
a worthless look imagine you're lucky
with that can you use it
we all a virgin out yeah i mean we have
to wait for the right woman on the right
time what would you guys rate yourselves
one to ten ten
[ __ ] ten baby
everybody's at ten that's the thing like
everyone is a ten everyone is unique
everyone is special don't you think if
it's if you're saying you're a ten
doesn't that mean you're perfect i'm
perfect
10 means that i'm unique there's no one
else like me in the world and there's
nobody like her there's nobody like you
there's nobody like him in the world
very unique really i think there's a
million people like me i think i'm not
you do not
know no we can't think like yeah
yeah we can be similar but we are not
the same i think the biggest lie we tell
ourselves is that we're special i don't
think that most people are special i
mean i think that's true
like what you're on about we are special
there's like a million people like do
like people come and go you know what i
mean no but everyone haven't gone but
like there's nobody like you everyone is
special everyone is unique everyone have
something different to someone else
where are you guys from tenerife where
then a reef canary island oh okay okay
wales okay i was like i didn't the
accents in london are always so i speak
spanish do you have any socials
instagram you wanna yes add
divinity with kirsty come learn to twerk
with me
for twerk after work i don't know if you
heard the brand but
yeah okay thank you guys appreciate you
have a great day is sleeping around
different for men and for women it's the
same like yeah it's just as bad yeah
it's not i don't think yeah someone's
worse like everyone is the same
for sure why why because
it's like a man has the key and a woman
is a padlock right
and
you know you don't want not every key
can open a padlock right so you have to
be special that sleeping around is
different for men and for women yes in
some ways why uh because it's more
normalized while it's not right i think
it's equally not right in both
situations but for men it's more
normalized so it's more of like their
society and it's seen as okay
yeah it's my different you know like i'm
gonna tell you saying yeah
you know the bad guy you can't trust him
yeah
she like bad money you know what i'm
saying
you can't trust these women out here you
know i'm saying
it's just a true fact
body count matter to you if you're
interested in a guy
and is he how many bodies is too many
bodies for you to date a guy five five
five so how old are you guys i'm 19.
yeah okay okay
so so if you dated a guy that was five
years older and he said i've slept with
10 women you would be out yes bye
run run
we got some wholesome women out here
oh god yeah i mean i wouldn't want to
end up with a black star how many how
many bodies there's too many bodies oh i
don't know i i i don't know and i could
be said if he said i've slept with 50
women would you care no it depends how
old he is as well how old are you a
woman never tells her right okay let's
say let's say he's 45 50 45. i mean it
depends what his lifestyle was as well
you know there's so many factors that
come into that but i just wouldn't want
a star or anybody that just sleeps with
anything i'm with you
you're not trying to catch it
so if you were dating a guy or like
you're looking to date a guy do you care
how many people he slept with it really
depends actually what do you mean i mean
if he's still into sleeping around and
he's not willing to commit then yeah i
do care but if he's committed then
maybe not but like it passed you don't
think matters as much for him yeah not
too much body count matters in general
no not really would you
would you say your body count
no
but it's interesting because if it
doesn't matter why don't we all just say
it i'm actually saving myself for
marriage oh i love that that's so sweet
i wish i did that okay uh why do you
think that women are looked more down
upon for sleeping around than men in
general because you're atypical from the
responses i've gotten today i think
because guys they get hyped up for it
whereas women get brought down because
they're like oh you slept with so many
men whereas men they're like yeah they
come on like they get ready for it
and there's always things like that
women can't do if you get it just like
for example football like oh one can't
do that
but like
yeah i don't know why we look
i don't know
yeah it's just weird yeah it's weird but
it's just the same like i don't care
okay what would you rate yourself one to
ten eleven
what did you say that that's saying
you're perfect said again what did you
say that's saying you're perfect oh my
god
eleven then like there's no room to
improve all right well i'm perfectly
imperfect how about that i'll say a five
yeah i'll say five i'll say i'll see you
with seven seven five cause everyone all
the girls i asked today say tens i don't
think you know yourself for ten you're
ten it can't be a ten
there's improvements that i need to
change like i need to change some stuff
about myself i'm not gonna no
it's a five just say i say five two and
i actually i would i like i would put
you above a five but like
but that's what i'm saying like i think
if if you think you're perfect like
there's no room to
can you improve you'll just assume that
you're always perfect no i can't agree
you guys you have any instagrams i feel
like my fans will like you my instagram
what's my instagram i it's run a car so
i t s r o n i c k a and mine is janae j
e n a e underscore xoxo so how many
bodies is too many bodies for you to
wife a girl oh oh my god
bad questions i miss i missed her i
don't know who's this is to you well i'm
gonna be roving 50 plus is too much
but she will never tell you
50.
she went over to the truth though
he thinks he's the undertaker 50 buddies
the cali will never take the truth okay
okay so if she has 30 you're cool with
that nah
no because honestly like i feel like
people should be like girls should be
virgins
yeah i wish i was but i'm not
okay okay so how many bodies is too many
bodies for you to wife a girl i'm saying
like 10-15
too much man okay so next next question
what do you rate yourselves one to ten
i'm at ten your time i'm a millionaire
what do you think what do you think
hundreds can i give you are you sure
i'll be very blunt i'll be very blunt
take off the sunglasses i'll tell you uh
one to ten
you can't be mad at me you can't be mad
at me
just you know i'm just i'm just gonna
tell you i'm going to tell you so this
is how i rate people eight to two i'm
gonna tell you i'm gonna tell you my
system eight to ten means you're a model
that means you would get a modeling
contract five is five is normal most
people are five six is cute i don't give
sevens because everyone thinks they're
seven i probably i'll probably give you
five secs
that's cool
that's cool to be fair i give nice but
to be fair i'll go to the camera she's
like bad mother okay yeah she loves bad
boys you know yeah
[Applause]
here's the thing here's the thing they
always ask me to rate them and they
don't want me to do it they don't want
me to do it
how many bodies is too many bodies for
you to wife a girl i don't think too
many bodies would be a thing it's up to
a personal choice if a person is okay
and open about it up front in the in the
relationship and and i'm okay with that
you wouldn't care if she like had a
hundred no i've been with someone who
has had over 200 oh gee and i didn't
bother you at all no why why well but
historically men wanted to ensure
paternity so i think there's some like
biological imperative that men typically
you might be atypical but typically have
when it comes like they're repulsed by
girls that sleep around right right so
when you talk to me like it's just
atypical right yeah yeah sorry i i will
be the odd one out here because a lot of
men like to be the one to you know get
this girl pregnant first or get this
girl in a relationship first but that
that's that's not possible you know
that's it's not natural nor i either way
so it's like you when you get into
relationship with someone you're in that
relationship because of who they are not
because of who they've been with or what
experiences that they had coming in but
you don't think that says something
about a girl like a lack of self-control
no i don't think so no because that's
just the experience that they've gone
through everyone's different so whatever
circumstances that they had to go
through to get there could be different
from your own i actually i understand
that mindset but like the thing is when
i started looking at the numbers i just
feel like i i couldn't not like if a
girl sleeps with more than five people
she is at 80
or um she has a 20 chance of not being
happy in her marriage after 10 years
where if she's only she's a virgin when
she gets married she has a 20 she has an
80 chance of being happy interesting i
think that's a lack of experience only
because they don't want to venture
outside of that comfort zone well it's a
lack of comparison
i would say yeah because like if you're
one of a hundred like what are what are
the odds that like you're going to be
the one she wants to be with um like
she's comparing you to 100 dude it's
pretty slim but if you're only comparing
the sexual prowess then that would be
one aspect but if you're comparing to
how you make that person feel or what
you can add to that person's life it's
completely different yeah but like as a
girl like i think i feel like a guy has
to be at a certain level for you to
sleep with him so you have to like have
some sort of emotional attachment
because like you're not sleeping with a
fat bum
you don't do what i mean but i do i do
well so when you say a certain level are
you talking about a certain income level
or are you talking about uh emotional
level i would say it depends but i'm
saying a guy has to have something like
like you you're you're what five ten
five eleven five eleven yeah yeah so i'm
saying like more girls are gonna sleep
with you because you're tall really yeah
because you're like that's five eleven
that's pretty that's the top that's
that's not a few friends who are five
five and they they sleep around with a
lot of girls well maybe they're hot like
they have to have something like i don't
i don't know what it is but i'm saying
like that's something that makes you
like i would never hook up with a guy
that was five five like it wouldn't even
never never but like like six foot like
my height ish like that's that's fine
but i'm saying like you have to have
something as a guy you can't be broke
and be a loser and get girls true true
definitely like income is a very um
heavy factor in that in that aspect but
also you have to look at the potential
you have for growing as a person is this
person going to be good for you in the
long run is this person going to help
you with your career is this person
going to help you with your passions is
this person going to help you become the
better you
or are you just trying to fulfill a
certain
you know pleasure aspect are you just
trying to fulfill a certain carnal
aspect are you just trying to fulfill
something that's going to fill a void
in this time or period if so then it's
only going to be temporary if not then
you're looking for something deeper no i
i agree with you like i think it's bad
when girls just go after guys for money
alone but but at the same time like i
think there's some innate
instinct we have that we want a guy
that's more competent than us and that's
why you see like girls that are lawyers
marry another lawyer or doctor like even
the most accomplished women that don't
have money doesn't have anything to do
with it like they still want a guy that
is their income or higher right well i
mean there's nothing wrong with seeking
someone who's going to benefit you in
some way that you don't see
because that's just a natural instinct
of trying to look for success but at the
same time you can find that elsewhere it
doesn't have to be where you're looking
do you think it's natural for men to not
want a girl that sleeps around because
just historically they had to ensure
paternity true true um i depend that's a
hard question i i think it depends on
what you're looking for or sorry this
this male is looking for in a particular
wife
true yeah if they're looking for a wife
then maybe they might not want to yeah
or if they're looking for a quick fling
then that's probably something that
they'll do yeah so if you had a daughter
like would you care if she's would you
encourage her to sleep around or would
you
would you
ah i would encourage her to make the
best decisions that she can make with
the information she has at hand only
because like that's how
strong
experience is made
[Music]
how many bodies is too many bodies for a
girl one one
one what are you guys's body count zero
zero
zero that's crazy everyone i interview
is a virgin there are a lot of virgins
in london
i'm not from london so me too um is
sleeping around different for men and
for women it shouldn't be no it is but
it shouldn't be i literally agree what
she said like i'm saying yeah it
shouldn't be different but yes it is no
okay why why yes why now well no
i say it's different because of the
perception of people if you sleep around
as a woman you're a [ __ ] if you sleep
around as a man you're good what's the
basis of the question which is basically
what you said
you're saying it shouldn't matter it
shouldn't matter
yeah i say the same i'm just saying in
reality it does matter yeah in reality
what do i think
she will not say no
i'll tell you i try to have
conversations i mean i think it does
matter if you look at the data like okay
if a girl slept with zero people and
she's a virgin do you know what her
chances of having a happy marriage
eighty percent
if she's slept with more than five it
drops to twenty percent
so it's like when i'm looking at this
and this is self-reported how do i argue
with that go ahead where's the
statistics on that so it's a study that
was done in the u.s and and they would
they would ask women how what's the
what uk excited different so so they've
done they've done similar studies with
women on like other things like like
higher rates of depression higher rates
of like like
it all kind of goes together i think
body count matters i don't think it
matters it shouldn't stop me from like
wanting to be in a relationship with
someone but i do like look at it and be
like hmm like i do kind of no i don't
think it matters no timon is this just
what you're comfortable with what the
person is comfortable with so if it
doesn't matter would you guys say your
body counts yeah well mine's literally
one so there we go one and proud zero
yeah seriously crazy everyone i've
talked to is a virgin today
a version or three or less but it's just
the only reason i ask is because it's
like we say it doesn't matter but
oftentimes they don't want to stay yeah
yeah no that's fair i don't care
i don't think it matters really i'm
transparent
like it's nothing yeah it's not a big
deal i don't think it makes someone like
less of a person at all i just i just i
just think like it's harder for women if
we've experienced more to be happy with
the one we have because we compare
that and i've seen a lot of girls like
where they're in love with their ex but
they're with the new guy what is your
personal experience with
what the um i get mixed answers some
people say it matters some people say it
doesn't i'm not saying i'm right or i'm
wrong it's going to change in five years
and what do you my my question
no i think it'll more personal
do i think it'll change what
you had
at some point yeah yeah yeah i have an
ex-boyfriend yeah yeah
um it was a couple years
[Music]
a couple years
yeah i'm 25.
what
you were 23 when you had this
relationship
yeah yes okay yes
what that does it make you
want to ask that question and at this
point
people typically give me like more
honest answers have you been here before
i'm lucky to sleep around for this party
for sure
have you been here to the festival no
this is my first time i've never i've
never heard of it this is someone told
me about it i should do interviews here
without a doubt i think you should have
two out of three you have to attend two
years and that's the same question guys
we're gonna talk to a guy and he said i
slept with 50 women would you care no it
wouldn't matter
um
i wouldn't like make that stop me from
being with him but i would i think
because i'm very respectful about
sleeping people i'd be a bit like i
would probably go lower i would like i'd
be a bit apprehensive like if you gave
me a reason why sort of like was your
mentality doing that was it just to earn
more women or was it because you like
them or sort of like it just depends on
the person well it's kind of like you
don't have the same values in a way yeah
yeah pretty much overall though it's not
a big deal but if yeah it's the values
thing yeah do you think it's bad if a
guy says he doesn't want a girl that
slept with so many people yes yeah i
think that's bad i think standards yeah
if he's got if he's also got a low body
count and so do i let's say i don't
think it's a big deal but if you've
stayed with 40 girls and then i've sat
with like one guy you're like oh i don't
need to sleep with that i think that's
just stupid like yeah
do you think sleeping around is
different for men and for women both you
shouldn't be sleeping around that's
disgusting ill how many bodies is too
many bodies
i don't think body matters if you really
like the person i don't think body mind
you don't think it matters i don't think
it matters no what's your body
my body cat body cows i can't really say
that
no the only the only reason i ask is
because a lot of times we'll say it
doesn't matter but no one ever wants to
say it no of course there was a
statement it doesn't really matter it
already matters if you're actually
talking with a person
and then you're out here doing [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay like you know you don't seem to be
doing that but if it was before you met
him you don't care or her i don't care
because i wasn't around
i wasn't around you know what i'm saying
so do you think it's okay for men to
care about that stuff
some men do but you know
i don't know i can't really answer that
question because you know i'm not a man
you know i just a lot of times like
girls will say they shouldn't care but
they do so i don't care personally
because i didn't know you
way back before so it's like you know
what i'm saying but if you're in a
relationship or talking to me i don't
expect you to be talking to someone else
you know i mean like we'll be doing
stuff with someone else does that happen
dude i don't really care has that
happened body count has that happened to
me
no way
no no it hasn't happened to me no
actually rate yourself one to ten i'm a
ten out of ten what does the cameraman
think
i'll rate you
oh i'll rate you
all right i give you i give you eight
actually eight yeah
okay that's good that's good that's good
i don't i think 10 10 means you're
perfect i don't think you're right
i think i think you're like pretty
enough you could model
i'm gonna give myself a 10 because self
love do you think that because i asked
this and this is like a common answer i
get today don't you think 10 means
you're perfect don't we all have room
for improvement yes well i think you can
always make room i think it counts do
you think sleeping around is different
for men and for women oh gosh i mean
definitely because men can just go
around and do whatever they want then in
the same time we're all human
like i get it to a certain degree but if
you're a woman [ __ ] 10 boys a boy
wouldn't want to go near her but if a
man did it
it would be fine actually i've
interviewed people on this today 10 is
right when you become not wifey it's
like at the 10 to 15 mark they're like
nah
just play but if it was a boy it'd be
different yes why i think women
i think when they do it it's more
emotional than when men do it i think
when men do it they're more thinking
about how they're going to feel
physically more than mentally and women
are more looking for an emotional
connection rather than something
physical i think that it is different
but it's starting to be
normalized that women can sleep with as
many men as they want to
just now i think within the last five
years with the rise of poly people are
more open to it but i think before yeah
it would be really different it would be
shunned upon and is how many bodies is
too many bodies for you to date someone
i don't think any really i think me i'm
not it should be
that wouldn't so do you think body count
matters if if i'm not gonna lie to if
i'm being honest if it was really
extensive then yeah i'd be a bit
slightly a bit more cautious in that
regard but i feel you can't just judge
on someone because of their bodycon i
just think that's a bit would you say
your body count
do i even know
no no the only reason i ask is because
it's because everyone says it doesn't
matter but no one wants to say it so
it's like if it doesn't matter why don't
we all just say it you would be open to
paulie yeah i found out a lot of people
here like are actually like more open to
that how how would that work
how would it work yeah like is it like
both sides can yeah i think you just
have to have an open conversation with
whoever your partner is and as long as
you guys are
in agreement and alignment then i think
that it works don't get jealous i would
get too jealous i couldn't
like think about it so everybody has
their favorite hairstyles everybody has
their favorite barber nobody gets mad
because their barber cuts more than one
person's hair
right you're just like oh this person
but i'm not i'm not in love with my
barber
some people aren't leave the barber i
could i could have i can't i've moved a
couple times i go through
but what i'm saying is think about how
they're so that would be the perfect
example of someone who is monogamous and
someone who's non-monogamous so someone
who's monogamous they they would not be
okay with you know sharing
their person someone who's not
monogamous would be like oh okay it's
cool do you think the more have you ever
heard of the paradox of choice
so it's like the more choices you have
the less happy you are with your choice
so they say that like the more women
sleep around the less happy they are
with the guy because they've already
experienced like too many i don't think
that that would be a factor i don't know
i think that if you were sleeping with
multiple people you would have a
connection with them i would hope that
someone would have a connection with the
multiple people they were sleeping with
so i don't have an answer for that it's
just it's interesting you know that the
longest marriage is around they're both
virgins wow
yeah i mean it's not i don't think like
i talk to men and women and i think like
the men are like no we should sleep
around they shouldn't and
and the women are like now we get to
sleep around too but it's interesting
because the people with the best results
are like the virgins well i mean listen
i'm not a virgin so i can't i know i
ain't neither right
yeah
thank you thank you sleeping around
different for men and for women
don't know i say yes different for men
because men don't feel um attached to
the female i guess as much as a female
does that's my opinion i don't know it's
kind of special she only speaks in
german so can you tell me what she says
no she said she didn't understand the
question
she said she doesn't want to speak again
that's what she said if you're if you're
dating a girl and she says she slept
with 30 men do you care yeah how many
bodies is too many bodies one
[Laughter]
i'm joking
i'm joking who's this who's her who she
is why you only count the good ones
no i don't know i would say now i don't
care anymore but like when i was younger
i used to care more yeah why did that
switch for you was it like a lack of
wives
no just life experience i don't know i
think it's it gets better with the age
so so
now are are you married no you're
looking for a wife do you want to get
married at some point no oh so then then
what would it matter to you it wouldn't
matter no i don't want to get married do
you want to do one of kids yeah okay so
for someone you'd want to have kids with
yeah what how many bodies is too many
bodies wow they have to raise the
daughters right
wow i'll say i'll say 10 max 10 max yeah
that's what i would say i don't know no
that's typical that's like what i've
gotten today
damn she said she's over it
damn she got more than 10. that's what
she said
but she's young though 20. oh what at
20. so i can't marry her
what i can't marry her then
you want to be experienced and you want
to experience it but women shouldn't
have a lot of bodies no she asked me
like if i would get married yeah how
many men is too many men that's none of
your business it wasn't for you that was
the question here's
you i'll tell you i'll tell you but i'll
tell you i'll tell you why like it
matters because if if a girl is a virgin
and she gets married what's her chance
of a happy marriage 80
80 chance that in 10 years she's happy
she sleeps with five men it drops to 25
because the more
yeah
it's because like the more the more men
you've been with the more you're going
to compare
so it's like it's not healthy for you
yeah but but a lot but a lot of times
the but the problem is the best doesn't
usually want you because the best guy
has slept with everybody and so it's
like experience you got a point and get
the bit yeah but i'm saying like that
doesn't work because the older you get
the less valuable you are to guys
yeah because you you they value purity
in youth and so you have less about the
older you get
like like like you said you're 20 like
that's in the dating market like you get
more matches on dating apps if you're 20
versus 25. so if i switch the question
yeah like what would be your answer how
many bodies is too many bodies i don't
really care with a guy um i'd say i
don't want anything that's like been on
the internet so no like and honestly i
would say if a dude slept with like a
hundred girls like to me it's like he's
never gonna settle down he's just gonna
be in the streets forever
like you can't you can't because
nowadays like if you're in that small
percentage of guys that's sleeping with
everybody what incentive do you have to
settle down matter for you to like make
a decision on if you want to marry the
guy it wouldn't if he wanted to get
married but like to me like early on if
i found that out i would just be like oh
he's never gonna
you didn't say like like what are the
odds that like out of a hundred i'm the
one that gets him to quit no i'm not
that special i come what would you rate
yourself one to ten i'll say solid eight
what do you say to the people that rate
themselves as ten what do i say to them
yeah do you think that ten is perfect do
you think 10's exactly there's any
perfection yeah
i'm guessing i don't think that there's
anyone that could say that he or she is
perfect yeah that's why i said solid
eight so
eight in my ratio is a ten
no i'm just thinking because so many
girls today i ask they say 10. okay what
makes them a 10. i don't know i don't
know like what makes them attend if you
tell me what 10 is then it's because i'm
unique and i'm an individual so what
makes me unique that's what i said
nothing
i don't think
okay well thank you no worries fair
enough no no you're sleeping around
different for men and women the problem
is we're all a bunch of slags
so [ __ ] who you want and we're adults do
we do what i'm saying you don't think
it's different like if you're looking
for like long term with a girl like like
if a girl's been an only fans would you
wife her i might marry her stay at home
husband max
stay at home husband mike let the only
fan six figures i would never go to work
what if she's bad at only fantasies
what if no one's buying it
then there's a secret between me and you
it's a little kinky secret between me
and you yeah the sales aren't hitting
but you got a little it covers the
starbucks every now and then so
so if you're interested in a girl she
slept with 100 dudes you don't care i'll
step up 100 women okay let's play the
game
what if it's a thousand i'm okay okay
we're growing people because when you
sleep with growing people shout out to
nancy's when you sleep with growing
people you look at [ __ ] people sleep
with people i can't be in there doing
like
figures and facts
you [ __ ] my man but if you slept with
a bum he was homeless nowhere to stay
i'm judging you a little bit i'm judging
you just a little bit like is that about
how many two
quality quality standards you don't want
a hundred quality men well i'm not
saying i don't want you to have 100
quality man yeah percentages
oh okay it's just gotta be more at least
80 percent of quality 20 he caught you
on a bad day what's your body count mind
your business you said it's over a
hundred i never said that you said that
no you did earlier i couldn't i didn't
say that you said if she's 700 people
and then you said i've slept with over a
hundred thousand yeah you did i stepped
up 100 women okay let's play the game
i have it on film i'm a liar i'm okay
okay
i'm okay with that let the streets know
virgin mike's